les Trappistes reçues trois sur trois en
2023 l'Étoile Sportive de Trappes
enchaîne avec une troisième victoire
consécutive le résultat 1 à 0 une
rencontre difficile face aux valeurs aux
joueurs de Garen Colomb les voisins des
Hauts-de-Seine n'ont rien lâché jusqu'à
la fin de la rencontre ça a été un match
très difficile très serré au final les
deux équipes ont beaucoup beaucoup
défendus ont réussi à trouver la faille
sur
sur une action collective très bonne
action collective et bon on a réussi à
marquer ce but là qui a été important
parce que je pense que la première
équipe qui marquait sur ce match là a
gagné le match avec un score vierge à la
mi-temps la situation s'est débloquer en
seconde période contre le cours du jeu
Garen Colomb se procure plusieurs
occasions dont cette action face au but
juste après grâce à un enchaînement
collectif trap ouvre le score 1 à 0
on voulait les attendre un petit peu bas
on a été surpris par la hauteur du bloc
adverse et de ce qu'ils arrivaient à
proposer dans le contenu du jeu on a
fait rentrer un attaquant avec un profil
un petit peu différent qui pesait un
petit peu plus sur la défense au but
je pense que ça nous a fait du bien ça
nous a permis de positionner le bloc
équipe un petit peu plus haut sur le
terrain jusqu'à la fin du match Garen
Colomb presse sans trouver la faille
dans la solide défense des Yvelines
trappe s'impose et poursuit sa dynamique
positive les automatismes commandent à
prendre une vraie une cohésion de groupe
est né donc tout se passe mieux au sein
du groupe maintenant il va falloir
travailler pour entretenir la dynamique
positive et aller chercher tous les
points qu'on peut qu'on peut aller
chercher par rapport au début de saison
déjà on est beaucoup mieux et on est sur
une bonne dynamique la dernière défaite
remonte au 10 décembre 2022 face à
Houilles trappe pointe à la sixième
place au classement prochaine rencontre
dimanche 12 février avec la réception de
Conflans